Biden is a proven failure the country is
in shambles that guy I mentioned who
talked about executing j6ers also said
it's Biden's fault the economy is bad so
my point is just they can't try this
game twice and I do believe they're
going to try they're putting up polls
where it's like if an election was held
today Biden would win DeSantis would
beat Trump but Biden uh they're saying
that DeSantis would beat Biden but and
Trump would lose to Biden and they're
trying to make the case that we should
support DeSantis for the primary I think
they are lying once again in the polls
so can I validate what you're saying
yeah can you go to a website it's number
270to win.com this is yeah this every 10
years we do a census as mandated by the
Constitution most people don't know this
but the map has slightly changed in
Trump and the Republican favor for the
first time for 2024